well what a packed program I have for
you today starting with economic news as
predicted completely cluelessly by me
feeling around the dark and knowing and
feeling around in the dark and knowing
absolutely nothing about anything uh
inflation has declined we now have seen
a lower than expected inflation number
this morning this is what I've been
saying for months and since we got the
June numbers in July inflation year over
year after the June numbers we received
in July were at 9.1 percent now we are
down to 8.5 percent coming in below the
expected 8.7 percent now the way that
corporate media reports these numbers
continues to be so confusing look at
this headline from CNBC consumer Prices
rose
8.5 percent
in July
less than expected as inflation
pressures ease a bit
this is good news but the reporting
makes it sound like in July of this year
prices went up 8.5 percent
that is not the case what this number
means is that for the 12-month period
ending in July prices are up eight point
five percent so another way to think
about it would be
in July we got the inflation numbers
from June 2021 through June 2022 and
that was 9.1 percent now we are adding
the numbers from July 22 and removing
the numbers from June 22. so this new
number is for July 2021 through July
2022. there must be some simpler way to
report this so that people don't get as
confused as they get but the important
thing is this is good news for an
economy that otherwise looks quite good
essentially full employment
gas prices declining stock market at
least over the last six weeks looking
significantly better than it had looked
in the first months of 2022 a lot of
these things look good again considering
that these are the traditional economic
indicators and if we continue to see an
inflation decline which I expect that we
will as as gas prices in the first 10
days of August has continued down that
is going to be a very good thing now one
other important bit of news here real
average hourly earnings for all
employees went up 0.5 percent in July so
this is another element that makes the
economy look relatively solid which is
not only did we see inflation decline we
also saw wages go up which this concern
about buying power for the average
American is mitigated to some degree by
prices down and wages up now is there
still Poverty of course is there still
still hunger of course inequality of
course this doesn't mean we've solved
the economic problems that we have and
that are in inherent to the economic
system we have but by the indicators
that we pay attention to this is a
significant Improvement now what's the
right wing story going to be I don't
know I mean listen inflation's down
stock market's up gas prices are down
hourly earnings are up somehow it must
be very bad for the country and for Joe
Biden I don't know what they're going to
say probably well inflation is still too
high yeah okay but it's lower than
expected and it's declining so we'll see
what they come up with
many people are shocked when their
identity is stolen but it's actually one
of the fastest growing crimes in the U.S
I've dealt with it it's a terrible
feeling and that's why I now protect
myself with aura one of our sponsors
Aura monitors email addresses passwords
social security number bank accounts
credit cards and I can set it up to
instantly get an alert on my phone if
something happens and then Aura goes
through the process of fixing it as well
Aura also does things like make sure no
one's opening up bank accounts or credit
cards in your name or it takes all the
tools you need to protect all of your
accounts and devices puts them in one
easy app Identity Theft Protection fraud
monitoring password management antivirus
all in one place at aura.com Pacman you
can try Aura free for two weeks you can
do things like check whether your login
credentials have been leaked the whole
world might know your email password
right now and you can find out for free
I found an old password in four
different data breaches the link is down
below